so it's not only chris matthews on msnbc
that in his panic about bernie sanders
recent primary and caucus successes
likened bernie to nazis we've actually
been covering the disinformation
propaganda
and the memes that have been spreading
and the american right
is in as much of a panic over bernie
sanders
as is establishment corporate media and
the democratic party establishment and
the right is now starting to spread
disinformation
equating bernie to hitler now i want to
look at one example today
which in six different ways suggests
that
bernie sanders is like adolf hitler
now we have to suspend disbelief for a
moment because
when you say yeah the jewish candidate
whose family members were killed in the
holocaust
by hitler's nazis is like hitler
immediately most people would say that
doesn't make any sense david let's
ignore that for now and just look at
what they assert let's look at these one
by one the meme
claims that both hitler and bernie
believe state power will fix their
respective countries
it's important to point out that bernie
sanders
has no interest in increasing state
power
and in fact bernie has been critical of
how donald trump has exposed that the
executive branch probably has too much
power
because trump has been able to
completely flout and ignore
laws and norms and do whatever the hell
he wants
so it is simply not true that bernie is
looking to increase state power
uh for these hegemonic authoritarian
reasons that hitler wanted to do that
what bernie believes is that government
involvement in a sensible and controlled
way
will make some of our systems better
function there are systems that aren't
working well
that have turned over too much power to
the rich into corporations at the
expense of the average american
bernie believes government involvement
in those systems will be better for the
average person
secondly they argue bernie and hitler
are the same because they both proposed
gun control
now this relates to a meme that has
spread
that the jews were disarmed by nazis
and if the jews had not been disarmed by
nazis and had rifles and handguns
they could have successfully resisted
world war ii
period that has been widely debunked
it's an
entire we could do an hour just on that
but it is both factually wrong and it's
wrong in its conclusions
bernie wants sensible gun control that
most americans agree with
gun control was already strict in
germany
before hitler came to power historians
agree that guns
would not have allowed the jews who made
up just one percent of the german
population at the time
to resist the third reich and the idea
that one percent of the population with
pistols and handguns was going to take
out take out a very well-armed police
state
uh uh that ultimately became and worked
with
and molded into melded into the third
reich is silly at its face and has been
widely debunked
the third bullet point is both hitler
and bernie promise political revolution
now in a sense so did donald trump a
revolution
where the swamp would be drained
political insiders would no longer have
power
he failed to do it but this idea of
revolution
is so vague that it becomes meaningless
hitler's revolution was one of a
hegemonic germany
invading other countries and killing
jews
likening it to bernie sanders wanting
the
the u.s to be more like the social
democracy of denmark
where people get health care and public
college paid for
through taxes is laughable it is a
semantic
game that they are playing number four
they bring out the term
socialist the uh right-wing
disinformation meme says hey hitler
called himself a socialist and bernie
calls himself a socialist now of course
national socialist abbreviated as nazi
has nothing to do whatsoever with
democratic socialism or in reality with
social democracy that's what bernie
sanders
is proposing this is a semantic
confusion that's being used to trick low
information people
who don't really know much by throwing
the word socialism in without any
context
number five hitler blamed jews for
germany's problems while bernie blames
the rich for america's problems
this is a really important one bernie is
not so much blaming the rich
for problems now even if bernie was
blaming the rich
blaming the rich is very different than
blaming the jews but put that aside for
a second
bernie doesn't blame the rich bernie
points to the super rich
as evidence that the system is not
working and needs to be reformed when
bernie says look at
the super rich in corporations who often
pay little
or less in taxes compared to people who
are just middle class
that's evidence that the system isn't
working the richer a side effect
the rich aren't the problem as
individuals
a very very deceptive component and then
lastly
both uh hitler and bernie wanted heavily
regulated economies and again this is
just a semantic game
a regulated economy could mean anything
from a communist centrally planned
economy
to social democracy or even a
totalitarian police state hitler wanted
to get involved
in the minutia of people's everyday
lives in the authoritarian sense
determine who gets to live who gets to
procreate
bernie wants to regulate the economy to
prevent bad actors in industry
and uh bad actors who limit the average
person's ability to just live a happy
life and pursue happiness
so this is one of those examples where
you see the full list with the deceptive
language and you start to think man
maybe bernie is like hitler in some ways
the merest superficial analysis confirms
that this is merely disinformation
and uh something that we need to protect
ourselves against
given the nature of the nature
and the scope of the disinformation that
is floating around already in the
democratic primary
very very ugly stuff but we will do our
best to debunk it
if you watch the david pakman show you
should check out
a youtube channel we're partnering with
called up
flip click the link right underneath
this video it'll take you to their
channel
while you're there make sure to
subscribe and click that bell for
notifications
up flip is a channel perfect for anyone
like me
who's fascinated with small businesses
and entrepreneurs and what makes them
tick
and every wednesday up flip uploads a
new video where they interview an
entrepreneur
they give you an inside look at how the
business works what makes the business
successful what a day in their shoes
is really like if you enjoy shows like
shark tank i think you'll really like
this channel and again the channel is
called up flip they're friends of the
david pakman show
i'd love it if people in my audience
subscribe to their channel
click the bell so that you get updates
about their videos and i've put a link
right below that will take you directly
to their youtube channel check it out